this video will review the available
content on Khan Academy and discuss how
our courses are designed to help
students Master the content they're
learning when Learners interact with
Khan Academy they will experience videos
articles practice questions and instant
feedback to help them improve when we
think about the resources Khan Academy
contains think of them split into two
categories the videos and articles are
instructional content and the practice
questions are practice content together
our goal is to provide Learners a growth
mindset experience and authentically
learn until they have mastered the
content a key part of that practice is
they'll get instant feedback about how
they're doing alongside worked solutions
to help them get back on track if
they're not quite clear on a particular
concept we know many educators are
familiar with Khan Academy's great math
content but many are unaware Khan
Academy has a a lot more to offer take a
moment to explore the dozens of courses
available to you including courses in
The Sciences finance and economics art
and humanities
additionally we have test prep content
including our digital sat course created
in partnership with the College Board
another example that we're excited about
here at Khan Academy is we're excited to
introduce our financial literacy course
the financial literacy course helps
students and their families understand
money better making it easier to reach
goals and avoid financial problems to
check out and browse all the courses
that we have available simply click on
the courses button in the upper left
hand corner of your Cod Academy account
as teachers we know you have many
options when it comes to using Tools in
your classroom so you might be asking
yourself what makes Khan Academy's
content so unique well Khan Academy's
content is not only interactive but our
content is standards based ensuring that
it aligns with educational requirements
and allows teachers to seamlessly
integrate it into their curriculum we've
minimized the amount of work teachers
need to do by offering a wide range of
resources exercises and videos that can
be easily incorporated into your lesson
plans and daily instruction this means
you as the teacher can spend more time
focusing on your students needs and
guiding them towards success our content
is student friendly and encourages
growth mindset by letting students know
that they can learn anything we want
students to feel like they are receiving
personalized support we hope this video
provides a look into the content
available on Khan Academy but we know
the best way to learn is to actually
experience it choose a topic that
inspires you and explore it
[Music]
thank you